My powers are not a gift
but a curse
it's born out of rage
black adam
you believe you are not worthy
but you have two paths
you can be the destroyer of this world
you can be it's savior
the world needed a hero
instead it got me
Welcome back everyone they dropped a brand
new black adam trailer so we'll break it
down there's a bunch of easter eggs dc also just
announced their 10-year plan for movies a lot of
you asking me like what's happening with dc movies
now because they had a big earnings call at warner
bros about all the stuff they were canceling
and all the stuff they were continuing with
literally everybody was talking about it
in their feeds even people who don't watch
dc movies at all were clowning about it in their
feeds so i will explain what's going on with
that and what their plan is for like the next 10
years if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos there's a bunch
of really big stuff starting really soon a bunch
of big episodes for a bunch of different series so
even though it does seem kind of like a bloodbath
right now with what's going on with dc movies and
dc tv shows there is still a lot of really big
stuff coming up through the rest of the year but
because everything they announced for the future
of dc movies for the next 10 years is so big i'll
start with that then i'll talk about the trailer
footage like everybody wants to know what's going
to happen with the justice league with all the
different movies everything they're canceling what
are they not canceling so basically as everyone
predicted what they announced to the big earnings
call is that they're combining hbo max with the
discovery plus streaming service next summer
at least in the united states around the world
it's going to be the same but it's going to take
a little bit longer for it to happen in all the
countries around the world and as part of that
the ceo the new company is trying to erase like
three billion dollars of debt from their books
and as part of that they're basically canceling
a bunch of different series not just a bunch of
dc tv series but a bunch of series that warner
brothers owns was getting ready to make or had
just started making in order to try and get rid
of as much debt as possible also they made this
big thing about how they're going to release all
their movies in theaters first now they're gonna
go back to the old model like they release a
movie in theaters then they put it on digital then
they put it on their streaming service and they're
not gonna release anything that they don't feel
like is like a big blockbuster event like a huge
big spectacle movie in theaters and they said that
they didn't feel like the batgirl movie was like
that doing that and clearing debt off their books
is basically why the batgirl movie got cancelled
like the new ceo said it's all about their
whole idea that they don't want to release
something that's not like a giant big spectacle in
theaters and that's what they're planning on doing
so the real big thing that they cancelled was
actually them just doing smaller movies that
were exclusively for their streaming service then
the ceo said that they're doubling down on content
like they're spending way more money on content
it's just the way that they're releasing it is
changing and this is true for all the dc movies
all the big budget dc hbo series that they've been
working on or are currently working on like james
gunn said don't worry guys peacemaker season two
is fine like we're still making it we're still
making all those batman hbo spin-off series of
the robert pattinson version of the batman movie
most of the tv stuff they're cancelling was stuff
that was either really long in the tooth like
it was in the later seasons and was coming from
a different network like the cw dc tp shows that's
why the flash basically ended because it's hitting
season nine so they're like okay time to end
the show we're not making money on it anymore
so there's no reason for us to do it anymore the
same is true for all the other cw dc tv shows
that means that superman and lois will probably
go for at least like another couple seasons and
then they'll probably end that around season four
season five so when it comes to all the stuff that
they're cancelling and all the stuff that they're
continuing with it just depends on which network
it came from and what they originally intended it
to be is it a spin-off from the dc movies in some
way or spin off one of the dc movies recently and
was it designed to be like one of these big budget
hbo series like the marvel disney plus series it's
just that there were like a billion different dc
tv shows there were some animated shows there
was some cw dc tv shows that were from like
completely different groups of people that they're
slowly kind of sun setting in the background
that's why they basically killed the air over so
to speak like the flash was like the last legit
core air over show to end because superman alois
takes place in a completely different universe
they used all this big terminology like a
big reset for dc movies this new 10-year plan
they specifically mentioned marvel studios and
kevin feige as being sort of like their benchmark
for what their new plan is for the future of
dc films what that means though is that they're
all about the interconnected universe so if you
really like what zack snyder started to do with
the snyder verse like these interconnected
movies and all the different superheroes
they want to eventually do a version of that
whereas that was not the case before like
you have a bunch of different characters like the
joaquin phoenix joker film the matt reeves batman
all the other core dc eu films like aquaman 2
wonder woman 3 even shazam 2 and the black adam
movie are dceu films between all those films those
were all in like completely separate universes
and they were gonna try and tie everything
together with the flash movie in the multiverse
now it sounds like with their change in direction
with them really wanting to double down on this
interconnected universe they're gonna try
and make some tweaks to the way the flash
movie works so that this does all make sense
like somehow you are able to tie the joaquin
phoenix joker to everything so that eventually
you are able to tie the matt reeves version of
the batman character to everything because it's
a 10-year plan that basically accounts for about
three more justice league films like they're
talking about like a new trilogy of justice
league films basically with a new roster of the
team zachary levi teased what one of their plans
were before all this big buyout talk happened
but it's not too different from what their new
plan is going to be because you have all these
brand new characters coming into the universe
they also want to work them up into a big justice
league team too it's kind of like avengers 5 kane
dynasty in avengers 6 secret wars where you have
a bunch of new characters coming into avengers
films but a lot of us theorized last year after
the rock started posting about this is that he
started putting the justice league on notice so
to speak in a lot of his promos especially the dc
fandom promos like everyone do me a favor tell
the justice league that i'm coming for them
they will eventually do a justice league versus
black adam film so to speak where you tie a lot
of these brand new characters to the core justice
league characters the big thing though is that
everybody's just wondering who's going to be
directing it and which actors are they going
to use for a lot of these characters because it
really does seem like warner brothers wants to
get rid of ezra miller as the flash like there's
just been so much drama with him why don't we just
bring in another version of the flash if we're
setting up the multiverse it's really easy to
explain how you have another version of the flash
show up short term they don't have any huge plans
to change their release schedule for the movies
that are coming out though so like all the movies
that you heard about that are coming out in like
the next year or two those are all still coming
out the other big changes they did say that
there was a priority on say like superman the
other core dc eu characters so i would expect
to hear news about a brand new superman film
or superman being a main character in like one
of the next big films in the next year or two
i've already done a couple videos about this
everyone just hoping that they bring henry cavill
back because he's been so quiet lately there were
all these rumors about him coming to comic con
with them making a big announcement it sounds like
they were waiting till after this earnings call in
like the 10-year plan for the future of dc movies
until they announce what's actually going on with
some of these characters so for those of you that
want henry cavill to come back as superman i keep
saying how the rock is basically like his best
chance to do that that is more true now than
ever but just in general the future of like the
next like three or four years is building up to
that next justice league film where it's like the
justice league versus black adam for the most part
and that's how they also explain shazam joining
the actual justice league so when you see the rock
posting all these jokes about how the hierarchy
of the dc universe is about to change in talking
about how the black adam character is the future
of the dc universe that's kind of true like they
are really using this character as a big piece in
the future of dc films in the next couple of years
but like i said marvel studios plan spinning off
disney plus shows from the marvel movies they're
doing the same thing with dc films expect more of
these big budget dc hbo series to be spin-offs of
the upcoming movies but like the justice society
for example big teen that are debuting in the
black adam film they might do a justice society
film and then do a justice society disney plus
series after that but now talking about the new
black adam trailer footage that they release
so they just start with a quick version of his
origin story where you see him in the flashbacks
getting the powers seeing the death of his son you
have this voice over from black adam himself and
dr fate where they talk about the nature of his
powers and the directions he could take in the
future where they think of his powers as more of
a curse than a blessing as opposed to the shazam
character who thinks it's this amazing thing that
he has powers now but now in present day dr fate
hawkman are trying to convince him to help them
and the new version of the justice society defeat
inter-gang in this new sabah villain that's
coming from the comics and through that him
sort of realizing the responsibility he has to
his people and that's going to set him up as
the ruler of kondok like he is in the comics like
why is it he wants to be ruler over his own nation
when he has all these superpowers we get a bunch
of new footage of doctor fate using his powers
you see him deactivate his powers but he's always
holding the helmet with him i've talked about this
in previous videos how the powers of dr fate like
the helmet of fate and naboo are kind of a curse
more than a blessing and they're kind of using
that as a parallel for the powers of black adam
they keep showing this ancient kondok figure
that the inter-gang villains are putting in a
stasis tube and a lot of people are confused
on whether or not this is like the d-powered
version of black adam like when he's deactivated
his powers i don't think that's the case it does
look similar to the rock but i think his head is
also just shaved and that's why people think that
it's the rock the thing about black adam that's
different from shazam is that when they activate
their powers what it does is that their physical
appearance gets transformed into whatever they
imagine their ideal appearance to be so for
instance billy batson who's a kid thinks that
the ideal version of himself is the adult version
of himself and that's why he looks like an adult
when he activates his powers but when black adam
activates his powers he already thinks that he
is the physical ideal of himself like he already
thinks that he is the best version of himself so
that's why his physical appearance doesn't change
when he activates or deactivates his powers and
obviously the rock is way more swole than this guy
which is why i think that this guy is not the rock
i think this is just meant to be a misdirect
because the intergang villains are trying to
harness the powers of sabac and the way his powers
work are very similar to the way that the shazam
family and black adam's powers work where they
take their powers from a god like gods grant them
powers sabach does the same thing but he's a demon
inside the dceu so the inner gang villains want
the same type of powers as say like black adam
but they're using an evil character to do it and
obviously that's going to go completely off the
rails which is going to explain why they have a
villain in the movie that's worse than black adam
and how you make him feel like an anti-hero but i
know everybody just wondering about the future
of dc films like what's gonna happen after the
movies that they've already announced so far
like i said they're just reorganizing things and
trying to interconnect everything the same way
that marvel movies are interconnected building
up to avengers films whereas in the dc films it's
them building up to justice league crossover films
when they make more casting announcements and
say what some of those other films besides like
the next justice league film are going to be
of course i'll do videos for it and we have
the black adam film coming out really soon expect
them to make more announcements about the future
of black adam versus the justice league after
that happens there's a bunch of other bonus
videos that i'm working on a bunch of trailers
that drop a bunch of big announcements i'll try
to post those as fast as possible everyone click
here for that first look at ben affleck's batman
coming back in aquaman 2 and click here to learn
about all the dc's stuff that they're cancelling
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!